so I guess I want to start by asking a
little bit about the origins of this
movie Leslie I know you had written a
book about Halston your uncle and I'm
curious had it always been your
intention to develop that further into a
movie or is it something Roland came to
you with how did it get started well it
was a little bit of both actually before
Halston died he gave me his archives
with the directive to write the book if
I wanted to and it took me 20 some years
to start digging through the boxes and
reviewing all the material in the
archives and I realized there was so
much more for the world to see than just
the book so Roland as a family friend
I've known him for a while and we had
spoken about doing something else with
the Halston legacy and so here we are
I'm so excited how did it start from
your point of view rolling over your
initial conversations like and how did
you see this movie well as Leslie
mentioned we've been friends for a long
time and a friendship started through
her brother George
Leslie wanted to do something about
Halston because so much about Halston is
somewhat flat the image of him you know
unfortunately through the years I people
don't have a very complete picture of
him they tend to think of studio 54
which was a part of his life but it
wasn't the only thing of his life and it
dominated the conversation so when she
wrote her book I think she did something
really great she she formed a picture of
a complete man and that when I read that
it's like okay now we're on to something
there's so much more than that studio 54
stuff we have a complete pitcher with an
amazing story that needs to be told and
how did you know that Frederick was the
director to tell that story well I saw
the Orang I and that did it for me
yeah I had seen a bunch of other films
and I considered other directors and I
didn't really like anyone's take I
didn't think that they were going to
push it forward there's no point in
doing the Halston story if you're just
going to tell the same thing over and
over again and then I saw Dior and I was
really taken by what Fred did which was
to tell the not the obvious story he
told the story about the back room and I
said I want that approach I want
somebody who take to do what to do the
Halston story in a way that no one else
has
Frederick you had done a bunch of
fashion films before as director editor
so was this something you were
interested in or did you kind of have to
get talked into it
I gave Roland a little bit of a hard
time in the beginning because I was
eager to sort of do something else in
fashion because you know I love I love
fashion I've I've I've loved all the
stories I've told in fashion but I was
you know I was telling Rowan what's the
biggest story beyond fashion and I think
deeper on a deeper level it after making
Joe and I I realized that I wanted to
talk about the place of creative people
within an industry I think I had been at
a board room table with corporate people
and realized that was very alone that I
was speaking a totally different
language and that people I was not
getting through to people were not
interested in making you know creative
decisions or you know a creative product
they were just interested in the bottom
line and so Halston story completely
resonated with me and devastated me I
was like wow this is the little bit that
I've lived through you know times a
thousand and and I wanted to understand
AHA that happened you know the more I
read the more complex the story got
yeah well it's such a complicated story
but I think he came up with a great sort
of structural device with the narrator
who's digging through the tapes the you
know fictional character I'm curious
where you came up with that idea and how
early in the process and what your
thinking was there I think it was pretty
early I mean I think it was really going
with my instinct that this was a very
big story and it needed a big frame I
was interested in doing something that
would maybe look and feel a little
different because Halston to me felt
like such a Nick mattock like person
there was something that I couldn't
completely unlock about Halston even
though I had all these different point
of views you know Leslie's all the
models the businessman everyone was
describing a different person almost and
there was something almost like a
rosebud missing in the middle and so I
started thinking of the
storytelling and how I could make this
fun for the audience just like it was
fun for me to discover to investigate
Halston reading because it became sort
of an investigation so you know this
time I had a bigger canvas and I had it
was like you know my second third film
or my subject and I was like let's you
know let's take a lesson from Halston
where you know who played all of his
cards at every turn of his career and
tried something new that maybe you know
could be divisive but you know if you
don't play you don't win basically
Stanley aside from the great score you
have a really great use of source music
throughout the film and I'm curious what
kinds of factors go into the decisions
behind the setting when you're gonna use
score when you're gonna use songs when
you're gonna let things play out
silently and and Stanley are you a part
of those discussions or did you just
hand over the music and find out what
what they did in the mix when you watch
the finished film it varies in my case
from film to film but and in this case
he had a great selection of I really
like the that Belva space in the front
there that's really nice and you know so
we had a nice collection there were some
things I had to sort of redo for
budgetary reasons you know but source of
music is kind of magical to me it's
sometimes it you know when you're
looking at a picture and it just you
just look at we need a song there it's
it's difficult to explain why just for
me I just now we shouldn't put score
there it should be a song or nothing you
know so and the source pieces in this
piece of right on spot on so and we were
able to use source music from you to
fake a fifty four five studio 54 scene
is basically a track 477 yes I mean no
it's 79 maybe it's a while ago well the
music really just unifies the whole
thing and it's it's a very seamless
smooth ride this movie but again so
complicated I'm curious what the editing
process was like how much trial and
error was there getting to this version
how many different versions were there
there are there are many versions I mean
mostly because this is a CNN film so we
have to do TV versions so that opened up
that that teaches you how to compress
your film and then you learn things and
you're like oh maybe we should use that
but also we did so with the the film we
show that Sundance is slightly longer
and we're going to release that on
Amazon I think later this year it's
gonna be the director's cut
quote-unquote and I mean I'm probably
the only one who keeps track of all the
different versions in terms of like
what's in it what's not but it was a
very very long editing process because I
really wanted it to play as you say like
really sort of seamlessly and because
we're working with so many different
parts so many interviews and then a few
scripted scenes and archival it was very
important for me that it became just one
thing and that took time to actually to
work out I was really impressed on the
section that Fred did for that
introduces Norton Simon the Liza
Minnelli song yes because that was a
case where he took a song which totally
embodied what he was trying to say and
made it the centerpiece and yet we've
done all this other historical archive
all the interviews and that was the that
was the one I mean it's all beautifully
edited but that was one scene that
really struck me and then I was so happy
were able to clear that song Eliza
helped us with Josh actually owns Liza
with a Z that's it's taken from and it's
the opening song and it's for me it
summed up like so much of what I wanted
to say about this moment that he takes
this big risk of signing his name off
and and I you know it was important I
never saw Halston as a victim throughout
this this whole his whole life I felt
like he really it might have ended
tragically but he had I mean an
incredible right and he when he signs
with Norton Simon I think he was I have
he had this very positive outlook on
life about saying yes and like taking
chances taking risk seeing the positive
you know not not necessarily
of consequences and so Liza's song is
like all of that encapsulated in like
Liza magic so it was just perfect for
you know for the middle of the film I
want to thank you all for coming and
sharing your thoughts on this homeless